sometime in the next decade the
international space station will begin a
slow descent from orbit
a gradual decline in its 400 kilometer
altitude
bringing the massive structure down to
thicker and thicker layers of our
atmosphere before it reaches a point of
no return
280 kilometers above our heads
from here air resistance will rapidly
slow the station and begin to tear it
apart disintegrating over a planned
debris field centered around point nemo
the furthest point from any landmass on
earth the south pacific ocean
uninhabited area
here in earth's watery spacecraft
graveyard the remains of the iss will
lay after over two decades of valuable
service to humankind
but this all begs the question
why crash such a valuable piece of space
infrastructure the iss has been growing
gradually since the very first
components of the station reached orbit
on november 20th 1998 the zarya cargo
module the first module of the iss
launched aboard a russian proton rocket
from kazakhstan zarya was the seed for
what was to come
carrying with it the docking electrical
power propulsion and guidance systems
needed to gradually grow what was to
become an unprecedented piece of
international space infrastructure
zarya was joined just two weeks later by
the unity module a module with two axial
connection points one on either end of
the module and four radial connection
points around its circumference
where the first truss segments would be
attached allowing massive solar arrays
to deploy and provide power for the
growing space laboratory
these sections of the international
space station remain in space to this
day providing for the needs of over 250
individual astronauts in orbit around
earth over the past 23 years
but this home in space was never
intended to be permanent and many
components are showing their age
the zarya module that seed from which
the entire space station grew
has developed several cracks that are
going to continually grow
cyclical thermal expansion caused by the
16 sunsets and sunrises the iss
witnesses each and every day stresses
the structure of the station and causes
these modules to gradually degrade over
time while jolts from spacecraft docking
with the space station can also cause
stress in the structure not to mention
the constant bombardment from
micrometeorites and space debris that
has damaged vital components of the iss
like the strike on the canadarm in 2021
mystery pressure leaks have even forced
astronauts into wild goose chases
seeking the source as their atmosphere
slowly vents the space
problems like this have been cropping up
more and more frequently as the station
ages
these modules part of the primary
structure of the iss are what will limit
the life of the station and at some
point the modules will need to be
retired
the question is when
each participating partner of the iss is
expected to inspect and perform
life-extending maintenance and while the
north american canadian european and
japanese space agencies have performed
these checks through to 2028
critically russia who have now become an
international pariah have only completed
these checks through to 2024 limiting
the international space station's
current lifetime to just two years
the war in the ukraine has thrown nasa's
recent transition and decommissioning
report which planned to de-orbit the iss
by 2031 into limbo without russian
cooperation the transition plan is
unfeasible as the international space
station was never designed to have large
sections of its structure removed to
allow a participating partner to cease
cooperation without russia we may only
have two years of operation of the
international space station left
potentially dooming nasa's future plans
laid out in the transition report
to understand what we may have just lost
let's dive into the decommissioning and
transition reports
nasa has been planning this
decommissioning for some time and for
good reason
the international space station cost
nasa roughly three billion dollars every
year with the cost split fairly evenly
between the costs of transporting
astronauts and supplies to orbit and
system operations and maintenance of the
station itself to put that into
perspective
3 billion is over 10 of nasa's total 24
billion dollar budget to really put that
into perspective the perseverance rover
mission cost a total of 2.7 billion
dollars
these costs are the real reason the iss
will be decommissioned
the transition reports lays out a plan
to decommission the international space
station to create up to 1.8 billion
dollars a year in budget that could be
used for nasa's moon colony goals
that's exciting in itself but is losing
the international space station in the
process worth it
well luckily the transition plan lays
out how nasa will not only free up 1.8
billion dollars of annual budget but
also maintain a presence in orbit
commercial space flight has rapidly
changed the face of the space industry
in the last 10 years in fact with the
current state of affairs with the war in
ukraine without spacex nasa would be
unable to send astronauts to the iss as
the falcon 9 is the only american rocket
fully certified for transporting humans
to the iss
it is this advancement in the private
space industry that is going to allow
nasa to maintain a presence in orbit
while saving enough money to fund a
perseverance rover every 18 months
the bulk of this money saving will be
achieved by offloading the development
and maintenance of the next generation
of orbiting space habitats to the
commercial space industry
nasa has long desired to do this and the
benefits are clear with the success of
spacex whose innovation and pricing have
forced the entire industry to adapt
the commercial industry is competitive
but in order to allow the commercial
space industry to flourish in low earth
orbit there must be something to sell a
viable economy must exist
in order to stimulate this new economy
nasa has conducted studies to identify
the most promising enterprises that
could find their home in the next
generation of space station
and several of these enterprises were
part of the transition plan for the iss
nasa identified a couple of key
industries that could flourish in space
the first of which is the entertainment
industry
imagine a world where the battle room of
ender's game is possible
that's a world that space entertainment
enterprises is seeking to create with
their spherical inflatable movie studio
they are slated to film an unnamed movie
with tom cruise as the leading actor
this however would not be a one-off
production the studio would be rentable
by anyone with a high enough budget
this isn't just a pie in the sky idea in
2020 nasa awarded axiom space a contract
worth 140 million dollars to launch a
module that would attach to the iss in
2024
which would provide accommodation for
private astronauts and continue
scientific research
this is the first step in a planned
expansion of a private section of the
international station which if
successful will be followed by
additional modules that would allow the
axiom space station to operate
completely independently from the iss
and expand on the other industries that
nasa identified as potentially
profitable space economies
and the space entertainment enterprises
module is part of this expansion plan
microgravity manufacturing was another
industry identified
manufacturing without the influence of
gravity has some major advantages that
are just waiting for the right product
that can justify the cost of shipping
raw materials to space
processes that are driven by gravity
like sedimentation convection and
hydrostatic pressure are eliminated
which affect manufacturing processes
sedimentation for example makes it very
difficult to create an evenly mixed
liquid as denser particles sink to the
bottom
say when we want to create an alloyed
metal with different density elements
these non-uniformities can affect the
material properties of the final metal
component so there is a huge potential
to create new higher quality super
alloys in space
this is just one of many potential
manufacturing techniques that could be
employed in space and we will discuss
the topic in detail in a future video
with the current transition plan this
axiom commercial space station will
detach from the iss in 2028 becoming the
new seat from which the space station
can continue to grow and provide a space
for future nasa astronauts to work from
with rental payments due to axiom and
transportation costs to spacex
there is a lot to look forward to with
that plan
but what are the chances this goes ahead
with russia's invasion of ukraine making
it impossible to work with them
russia's segments rely on america's
segments for power and the usa segments
rely on russian propulsion to stay in
orbit and avoid space debris
this is an international space station
that relies on international cooperation
it's clear that russian astronauts
oppose the war in ukraine based on their
recent uniform change but they do not
call the shots here
the reality is if this continues nasa
will need to make some major decisions
in the next two years
there are a few potential outcomes here
the russians separating their modules is
not one of them as they need that power
from the rest of the iss and would
struggle to complete that work without
the help of the canadian robotic arm
russia could under some miracle get its
[ __ ] together in the next two years and
remove putin's regime and continue
international cooperation in space
or russia's segments may not be
certified through to 2028 forcing the
deorbiting of the international space
station to be advanced with the
transition to a commercial space station
abandoned
alternatively emergency funds could be
allocated to nasa to rapidly supply the
iss with additional modules to replace
russian services like propulsion for
orbit maintenance and debris avoidance
allowing the transition plans to
continue as normal or the funds could be
simply allocated to the commercial space
companies to accelerate transition plans
but that is a massive ask for unproven
vendors in a two-year time frame one
thing is for sure the current structure
of the iss is on borrowed time its aging
primary structure is becoming a larger
and larger issue every year and at some
point in the next decade it will be
deorbited the only question now is when
it's hard to believe that the
international space station has been in
orbit for just over 20 years it's been a
huge source of inspiration for aspiring
engineers and scientists around the
world a frontier of scientific research
with only
253 individual astronauts from 19
different countries getting the
privilege to visit and work from the iss
it's seen by many as the pinnacle
scientific career achievement a joy only
a few of us will ever get to experience
luckily we can all get our little dose
of joy of scientific learning from
brilliant that dopamine rush of solving
a problem you've been trying to figure
out is what drove me towards a career in
engineering brilliant has refined that
fun interactive learning down perfectly
to motivate you to continue your
learning through difficult subjects
you can start your learning journey on
any number of courses from neural
networks and algorithms to statistics
and probability you can learn at your
own pace learn on the go with their
mobile app and most importantly of all
enjoy the process if you are stuck on a
particular question brilliant does not
punish you and impede your progress
instead they give you an in-depth
explanation to guide you on your
learning path you can try brilliant for
free with the link in the description or
by clicking the button on screen right
now
and the first 200 people to sign up will
get 20 off brilliant premium for a year
of stem learning in 2022
if you are looking for something else to
watch right now you could watch our last
video on the insane engineering of the
concord or you could watch real
science's new video on the science of
surviving in space
[Music]